yeah welcome to this five-minute game
Ted Ted later with the starting of the
recording in the video just a couple of
seconds and we got an English opening
with them c-45 black has some harm
interesting yeah of course you can you
can play out this candle set up okay
I'll prepare some Quinn side play there
are now be 50 okay yeah be five min be
five he needs to go to a five so it's
not very attractive but ok let's prepare
be five keep them a sounder pawn
structure if you need to go to a five
this already cannot be too great i mean
yeah no Knight a5 only move so the
question is how to continue I think I'll
go Knight f3 I want to have some
pressure on e5 so that GM cannot play d
5 but I also need to learn make sure
that I get down get cast out here so on
this is this is fine now yeah just as I
was thinking about Bishop g5 he's making
this move probably am a good one
so what now I don't think he is yeah we
should be too i'm not sure if there's a
maybe some point in moving the night but
ok let's do this first the thing is what
what is like doing he's got this
somewhat silly looking night yeah
exactly i was thinking he probably will
play something here but then my idea was
this and then c 5 which um should be a
good change of pawn structure i hope
this is a correct judgment not clear c5
don't know the questions can you play d5
if he cannot play d 5 then then I'm
mum's better this structure structure
wise now maybe he could have played d
595 Bishop c5 not Liam ok but this now
this looks some quite quite nice I would
I would turn think I take now and I take
a firefighters to see em how does he not
lose material not sure they're c6
hanging ok but this I thought would be
problematic would because I've got
knight c6 also if i take rook takes 96
just wins an exchange if the Queen takes
Knight c6 mmm
and it doesn't win material immediately
it is some looking badly but not seeing
them a direct win hmm this is weird it
absolutely looks like there should be
something going on I don't see it some
sort of a technical solution to this to
this position maybe there isn't get that
damn i just spent ages am I sort of
thought longer after before I take
because of course them correcting a
spawn structure is terrible if it
doesn't bring any immediate benefits and
I'm not sure about those benefits at the
moment really weird it doesn't look like
there is something so now i'm just i
don't have much more than exchanging
stuff p.m. yeah this i just played
battling it should be a rather
substantial advantage or move on move 16
or 17 and this now i don't know it's
probably a probably equal ish
yeah maybe it is some even still little
bit of something for white the pawns are
more of a weakness and then a strength
yeah I thought this would be actually
nice for me God rugby 7 coming
John shall not clear all yeah I have a
rupee seven at least threatening to take
and take a three day three rockets just
adjust loose in this position and
probably am needs to go somewhere back
to hold down yeah what do we add move
yeah maybe it's good even it just looks
strange somehow taking f5 don't really
know how to how to continue here group
III was strong probably okay come on
let's um get rid of the same the sounds
really nerve-racking the spawn not quite
short film this is really threatening
much Queen f1 I can go 23
i'm not sure i don't see how what this
is threatening I think I mean I've got
good control over this position time
morning yeah I don't test I don't have
time I mean so the position is it's not
not a problem at all check check check
check check grow powerful check guys
playing on time of course check check
check
like it's on time oh yeah now I'm
completely winning okay yeah it's
there's simply no increment time limit
IAM and auto pairing so that you can
avoid those those losses and I'm yeah
okay this is this is I'm probably a draw
his position what what he did actually
just is just suicide I'm Queenie for now
I Bishop before now Isis is winning
simply even but okay I don't have the
time to 30 seconds am okay I need to I
need to move at some point and this is
some this is completely winning for
white Queenie for his check made now in
a couple of moves it's very easy even oh
come on why didn't they do that I
thought I wanted to play Bishop to g6
now and just made him but of course then
there's rue catch one this is not
working and this now is some yeah yeah
just just just a mess with no time this
is this is a perpetual and which she
played on time of course to win all
right that's it